schon in der schule lernt man dass der
planet venus der nächste nachbar der
erde ist doch das ist wohl alles nur
eine sache der perspektive denn jetzt
argumentieren drei astronomen das ist
falsch nicht die venus ist der erde am
nächsten sondern der merkur und dichter
dass der neuen computersimulation
zufolge ist merkur außerdem noch allen
anderen planeten des sonnensystems am
nächsten
wie genau das forschungsteam auf dieses
ziemlich verblüffende ergebnis kommt und
wie wir merkur als unseren
offensichtlich waren nachbarn so lange
zeit übersehen konnten jetzt fertig zum
science fiction die gibt's täglich
faszinierendes 1 videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen wenn man sich bisher
darüber schlau macht wer der nächste
planet ist wird man auf die venus komme
auf ihrer bahn um die sonne kreist die
erde zwischen den ellipsen förmigen
bahnen vom venus und mars doch letzterer
zirkuliert etwas weiter entfernt von der
sonne als die venus diese kommt der erde
dabei am nächsten und so wird die venus
mit einem durchmesser von rund 12.000
100 kilometern als derjenige planet
bezeichnet der der erde von allen
planeten am nächsten kommt der minimalen
abstand beträgt laut der european space
agency esa gelegentlich nur 40 millionen
kilometer bei mars beträgt die
mindestentfernung demnach 56 millionen
kilometer
doch das alles ist wohl reine
definitionssache was also ist mit
megamind der planet der der erde ab und
an am nächsten kommt nein sagt ein
astronomie team in einem aktuellen
aufsatz stattdessen sei doch der
mittlere abstand zur erde entscheidend
anders ausgedrückt der planet der uns in
der meisten zeit am nächsten ist und
schon hat die erde einen neuen nachbarn
den merkur nämlich eine vorstellung
schließlich gilt der merkur als der
kleinste und innerste planet unseres
sonnensystems der zwerg hat lediglich
einen durchmesser von 4878 kilometer
dabei allerdings eine immense masse von
unvorstellbaren 330 millionen tonnen
merkur hat eine geringe schwerkraft und
seine oberfläche wird auf bis zu 34 grad
celsius aufgeheizt hier würde sogar blei
schmelzen doch nach den berechnungen des
forschungsteams befinden sich nicht nur
die venus
sondern auch der mars weiter von der
erde entfernt als der merkur
zumindest die meiste zeit demnach
beträgt der durchschnittliche abstand
der venus zu erde nämlich ganze 170
millionen kilometern gut 150 millionen
kilometer dagegen ist der
durchschnittliche abstand des merkur zu
uns denn auch wenn die venus uns ab und
an auf etwa 40 millionen kilometer nahe
kommt befindet sie sich den großteil der
zeit auf der anderen seite der sonne und
das forschungsteam klärt in seinem
aktuellen aufsatz noch mehr mit hilfe
von computersimulationen haben die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
auch die tatsächlichen positionen aller
anderen planeten in den vergangenen 10
tausend jahren analysiert bei dieser
berechnung kam heraus dass der merkur im
durchschnitt gesehen nicht nur die erde
am nächsten ist auch allen anderen
planeten des sonnensystems ist er im
durchschnitt der nächste größenvergleich
sonnensystem cooles video draufklicken
anschauen und astro comics tv abonnieren
bis dahin bleibt dran